SUBJECT: So I believe
that we are all wounded.
I believe that we
are all bleeding.
And I think the reason
that in romantic context
we are attracted to
others who are wounded
is because we feel that
by saving them, we in turn
save ourselves, right?
Romantic love as
defined by Ernest Becker
is a perfect consummation
with perfection itself.
We are purged in these
instances in which we
find another in whose eyes we
will be reflected and saved,
right?
This notion that we will see
ourselves being seen by another
who bestows us with light.
And ultimately, the crux
of the human condition,
the existential
impotence, of you will,
is the perhaps
tragic realization
that you can't save
the ones you love.
Those wounded birds, the
manic pixie dream girl--
you can't save her.
So what does that mean?
It means if you can't even save
the ones you love, how can you
save yourself, right?
This is the tragedy of
the human condition.
This is the sad song that
gives you the goosebumps
and makes you cry.
This is the lyric that
makes you tear up.
It is this acknowledgement
of something
that aches, of something that
is, of something that we wish
was not the case.
There is beauty in
this tragedy, but first
let us acknowledge
the tragedy of it.
And then we can make
a poem or make a video
or make a film to frame that
holy moment to at least cement
the tragedy by
saying, it happened.
We exist.
We felt something.
I've talked about
this before, but ugh.
It's why we make art.
"City Verite" is a
weekly series that
illuminates the life
and beauty of a city
by capturing a series of
breathtaking, intimate,
and eye catching moments
from a single day.
It shows the amazing yet
everyday elements and sights
that make places like
Brooklyn, Buenos Aries,
and Mumbai feel like
bringing things.